speaking of AI just just to go on that
tangent do you think it's possible to
have a future world at least to 50 years
50 100 years
where AI
there's an AI sort of central planning
sort of the we remove some of the human
elements that I think get us into a lot
of trouble like you could you can take a
perspective on the Soviet Union and the
flaws of the system there have less to
do with the different ideologies more to
do with the humans and the vacuums and
how humans feel vacuums and the
corrupting nature of power and so on if
we have ai that it's that's more data
driven and it's not susceptible to the
human elements is that possible to
imagine such a world almost like a from
a Sci-Fi perspective maybe in the future
you can imagine certain calculation
problems that arose during Central
planning solve through advanced
computing
but I would say that there's another
whole set of problems with the system
that were incentive problems and I'm not
sure how that advanced Computing would
solve the incentive problems of how do
you get people to actually produce
things that other people want
um kind of that informational question
and how do you communicate without
endless meetings or someone reading your
brain yeah what you actually want
um so so there's there's that kind of
informational question but then there's
the incentive of you know how do you get
people to work efficiently at work and
how do you get uh firms to
um to use their resources that they're
getting more more efficiently and I
think
so solving the calculation problem
solves some of these questions but not
all of them
but you know that's kind of a who knows
but if you're a vision of the future
requires some sort of
leap into technological unknown that's
very hard to advocate for it today it's
exciting to consider the possibility of
Technology empowering uh a better
reallocation of resources if if you care
about a kind of
uh the innate value of human beings and
think of the mechanism of reallocation
resources good way to empower that
equality that it's nice to remove the
human element from that like if you work
really hard
and you're really good at your job it's
nice to be really data driven in
allocating more resources to you
so kind of like I kind of think that the
agency part requires
human beings and conscious human
activity so I think if you have a sort
of
planning system that works
um and let's say the technology is there
for it to work
I would want it to be Democratic
planning in such a way there is a human
element there is some debate and
deliberation Society and also even in my
vision of socialism with the state
sector and state Investments and so on
I'd want there to be more public
discussion and debate about certain
things so it's not just left to
technocrats because you'd want to live
in society where you're you just find
out the next day that there's some
massive infrastructure project that you
haven't you know had a chance to
think about or debate or feel like
you're participating
in you know and and debate is not just
facts and logic that's that's why if if
the whole universe was about facts and
logic computers could do a better job of
that there's something about humans
debating each other that goes into the
difficult gray areas of
of what it means to be human or what it
means to have a life that's worth living
um
that requires humanity and I'm also
worried about while I'm excited by the
possibility of AI controlling everything
half joking but the reason I'm really
terrified of that is because usually
there's a possibility of a human taking
control of that system so you you now
start to get the same kind of
authoritarian thing well I am a human
I'm smart enough to be able to uh
control this AI system and I will do
based on what this AI system says uh
what's good for you it's kind of like
talking down to people and then use that
AI system to now have the same kind of
thing as holiday more in 1930s and also
our preferences might change so an AI
system might say the goal of humanity is
to just increase infinitely efficiency
or or increase output whereas we might
collectively decide that you know we we
have enough and we want to you know have
a trade-off right and I think that you
know we need a system that allows for
people to make
certain trade-offs
and have more of this uh Leisure that
I've been learning about from you this
is a very interesting concept